the Mac Studio is way better than a
specked up Mac Mini that costs more
right wrong at least for a lot of people
now I put this through everything I
tested out benchmarks real world
productivity tests I even pushed its
small cooling system to its limits and I
have to say I was extremely impressed it
honestly kind of blew my mind so in this
video I will give you guys a breakdown
of everything and share my honest
opinions now right at the get-go I have
to tell you guys know that I prefer the
max Studios design I love having that SD
card on the front I really wish this Mac
Mini had it and the two USBC ports that
you can get with the M1 Max or
Thunderbolt if you go for the ultra now
in this video I'm focusing on the M1 Max
but I'm going to provide benchmarks from
both the 24 Core 2 000 model and the 32
core M1 max if you spend the extra money
now in the back the port layout is very
similar we have four Thunderbolt ports
we have two regular USBS we have an HDMI
and an Ethernet now the Mac Studio comes
with 10 gigabit Ethernet whereas the
mini you have to pay an extra 100 bucks
meaning if we match up the ram the
storage and max out the M2 Pro it's
actually more expensive by a hundred
bucks than the base Mac Studio and that
kind of sucks on the flip side the Mac
Mini has a way more powerful HDMI port
that could support ak60 in 4K 240 frames
per second instead of just being capped
at 4K 60. now to me that doesn't matter
that much because I use the Thunderbolt
Port but that is really nice for some
people and for future proofing with that
this bad boy also has Wi-Fi 6E and it
has Bluetooth 5.3 whereas the Mac Studio
doesn't now at my house I actually
upgraded my Wi-Fi setup and using the
new router and everything allowed me to
go from 741 megabytes per second to
1162 realizing the full benefit bit of
my gigabit Ethernet so if you're paying
for fast in Ethernet Wi-Fi 60 could be
very helpful now I'm doing a full
detailed video about this and the
downsides and yes there are some so make
sure you guys are subscribed and with
that you want to subscribe for our
giveaway because we're giving away a 14
inch MacBook Pro and a Mac Mini so
there's gonna be two winners all I have
to do is be subscribed to enable
notifications and make sure you comment
Down Below on this video along with our
previous mid videos about these new Max
and Mac Mini and the upcoming lens all
the way to February 1st which is the day
that we're gonna announce the winners so
good luck now here are the full specs of
the machines I am comparing so you guys
can see that they are very similar they
are matched up with the SSD and the RAM
and that also means that we are not
limited by the slower ssds that Apple
has put in to their new M2 Pro machines
and our Mac Mini actually has faster
write speeds than the same capacity Max
Studios but slightly slower on the Reed
now getting into performance with
geekbench 5 the empty Pros have more
powerful CPUs we saw about an eight
percent increase in single core
performance and in terms of multi-core
roughly 20 percent better and that is
because we have slightly faster clock
speeds and we have two extra efficiency
cores which are also more powerful even
though these are not battery powered
devices now as far as metal graphics
performance the max Studios with the
higher GPU cores are 18 and 33 percent
faster now yes geekbench metal doesn't
scale all the way but the scaling is
equal between them so this 19 core is
not as powerful now let's dive deeper
into graphics performance I tested gfx
benches Aztec Ruins 4K and here the Mac
Studios were 16 and 52
higher frames per second which is a big
difference and that sucks for the Mac
Mini and then I tested out 3D marks
gaming test wildlife and here it was
even greater the 24 Cormac Studio got 22
higher frames per second and the full 32
core had 56 higher frame rates which
means if for some reason you want to buy
a Mac Mini for gaming well it is not
working out great but I think you'll be
impressed with some other graphics
performance coming up I maxed out the
cpu's rendering and cinebench and the
Mac Mini had about 20 percent higher
core than the max Studios showing off
that CPU performance now I definitely
saw this little system get hot and apple
likes to keep it hot so I wanted to see
how much wattage is pulling and it's
pulling roughly 22 percent more wattage
to get that extra power so we're not
getting any extra really efficiency
benefits to get that performance it's
just raw clock speeds and cores now when
I looked at the temperatures and the fan
speed
um I noticed that Apple allows this
thing to hit roughly 100 degrees Celsius
before it even turns up the fans and I
also noticed that Apple actually allows
the fan to run higher now 5000 RPMs
compared to 4 500 now I don't know if
it's a new fan but when I manually Max
it at 5000 RPM it was a lot louder than
the previous Mac minis but what is very
weird is that even after about 10
minutes of stress testing cinebench
apple is only running the fans about
23.50 RPMs and really liking and
allowing the system to run at around 100
to 101 Celsius they were fine with that
they try to keep it quiet and it was the
Mac Studio on the other hand barely runs
its fans it's practically at idle and it
runs much much cooler of course when he
took that thing apart half of the Mac
Studio is its beefy cooling system and
it does really show go now I wanted to
see will the Mac Mini thermal throttle
with its tiny cooler if you're not only
running a CPU task but maxing out both
which some programs and some tasks do do
so I ran 3D Mark and cinemench at the
same time and the Mac Mini hit 108
degrees Celsius before Apple decided
with the software to turn the fans up
higher after 10 minutes the CPU was
running at 98 degrees Celsius and the
graphics was running at 82 degrees
celsius compared to the Max studio where
doing the same test it was running at 71
Celsius for the CPU and 61 for the
graphics so the Max studio runs silently
and super cool and even under insane
load with that M1 Max now on the plus
side Apple didn't even have to reach its
5000 RPM that they allow it ran at about
4 300 while the temps were there and I
manually did Max it out and it helped a
little bit but not much the the positive
thing is knowing that even though this
cooler is small in here you're not gonna
have any thermal throttling issues now
before I show you more surprising
results I've got to talk about the best
magsafe iPhone case I've ever seen the
magic sand case from our partner case Q
now I've been using it for a while now
and not only have I enjoyed its design
it's fairly slim but the magsafe magnets
are insanely powerful but not only that
this whole ring actually is a stand so
you can pull it out and it works great
either way vertically horizontally where
some stands they kind of suck and
they're flimsy or they only work good
one way you can also use it as a grip
and it folds back flat so you can use it
with any magsafe accessories or Chargers
check it out by using link down below
and you can save 23 off your order today
and now let's get into some more very
weird and interesting results now for
all of you guys that do coding we ran
our xcode Benchmark and the Mac Mini was
about 35 faster this really makes no
sense to me because the processor in
here is about 20 faster as far as raw
performance but Apple's made a lot of
changes in these chips including better
memory caching uh beefing a lot of
different things up and it definitely is
showing so this is the fastest Apple
computer for xcode now for those of you
that do music production we also tested
out logic and here I expected it to be
really fast because you have better CPU
performance but in fact it was worse
than both the Mac Studio M1 Max models
now that is because this is clocked
higher and so you have a little bit
worse stability so in our track test
with different plugins it's called Uh
the New Logic Benchmark it actually did
slightly worse now for web browsing and
web-based applications and I know
there's more and more of them coming out
this thing is incredibly fast because of
a single core performance and because of
the memory it is extremely smooth and it
rocks any web-based task you throw at it
now I also thought that the M2 Pro Mac
Mini would be better for Affinity I
upgraded to Affinity 2 and I ran their
Benchmark and in the CPU it was faster
but by only 13 which didn't make sense
for the vector tasks and for graphics
which is what most of it is the Mac
Studios were 20 and 38
faster and Affinity is very well
optimized so I expected less of a
difference or even the Mac Mini possibly
winning but it didn't now I also tested
out Lightroom classic which is what I
use and a lot of people do and this is
where I was kind of Blown Away exporting
my standard 50 raw 42 megapixel edited
images the Mac Mini actually beat out
both versions of the Mac Studio now let
your room now uses both the CPU and the
GPU uses a lot of memory and I just
didn't think it would win but it did I
also created a massive Panorama using 10
50 megapixel Rod images and once again
the Mac Mini won the other two and by a
bigger margin this time and I think that
has got to do with the improved cash in
the M2 Chip and the other things that
Apple improved so if you use Lightroom
my goodness this thing is great I also
want to test out Photoshop where I
created a very large HDR Pro Image and
here the Mac Mini beat out the 24 core
Mac Studio but not the 32 core M1 Max
now this uses a bunch of graphics and of
course those have better graphics
performance but it's still beat out the
Mac Studio bass model which is
impressive getting into 3D rendering I
use the latest version of blender using
metal and for the basic easy BMW the
task the Mac Mini lost it was 11 slower
than the 24 core and 25 slower than the
32 core and you would say that makes
sense as worse graphics performance but
take a look at this I also tested out
party tug which is a lot tougher it's a
lot more memory intensive with different
shaders and here the Mac Mini actually
beat out the 24 core Mac Studio despite
having five less cores now the 32 core
did win but this got me thinking why are
we getting such a flip so I tested out
our tough memory test for blender that
needs a lot of or at least very fast
memory and the M2 Mac Mini one this time
around beating both Mac Studios so
basically what we found out is that
these new Mt Pro chips really Excel when
you have a lot of memory that needs to
move very fast so if you do tough 3D
projects or large ones it will actually
beat out an M1 Max Max studio now let's
get into video editing and this is where
things start to change because the M1
Max chip and of course the M2 Max they
have dual encoders so they are designed
to be really good at this now what
really surprises me is when I stabilized
a one minute 4K clip the Mac Mini
actually won it's so fast at processing
a lot of memory intensive tasks of
course I use a lot of Graphics as well
but when we switch to encoding regular
h.264 4K it definitely lost with its
single encoders the same thing goes for
hevc now I have these graded with film
grade and applied it is also quite a bit
slower now since those previous exports
were limited by the encoders I wanted to
throw something a little bit tougher for
them to do the first thing I did is I
exported 8K red footage and this is
really maxed out by the GPU so all of
them are maxed out that's the limitation
nation and the 32 core M1 Max definitely
beat everything else out but I'm
surprised how close the M2 Pro was to
the 24 core M1 Max and the same thing
goes if you're exporting to prores
because the graphics is the limitation
itself now I also exported some 4K
programs raw to prores and here all of
them lined up very similarly and I'm
guessing that's just because there's so
many different things going on with the
decoding of the RAW graphics but if
you're looking at just proraz encoding
performance uh the M1 Maxes they
definitely are ahead because of their
dual encoders compared to the single one
so overall I would say if you are a
video editor I would go for the Mac
Studio you also get those extra ports
and the SD card reader but if you work
in Photoshop a lot in Lightroom
surprisingly the Mac Mini does better
the same thing for coding tougher
blender projects and and some of the
other things I talked about like
web-based apps uh it really kind of
surprised me so if you were thinking the
Mac Mini is a terrible buy when you get
close to the price of Mac Studio well I
think you are wrong because it is a very
good machine now we don't think that
apple is going to update the Mac Studio
to the M2 Max and Ultra chips for a
while they might wait another year so if
you're trying to buy one not only do you
get the better HDMI the better wi-fi but
overall it is a very solid machine now
we're also going to be testing out this
full spect one that's unbanned to the
cheaper more affordable 1300 model and
the M2 version as well so if you're
trying to decide which one to buy make
sure you guys click that Circle above
and if you want to pick one up use the
YouTube shopping feature down below
we'll have all these linked check out
one of those great videos right over
there that's been Max and I'll see you
in the next one
foreign